i can't save everyone
welcome to your weekly ticket
well folks unbuckled their belt and
notch after their thanksgiving feast and
ventured to the cineplex where there was
a cornucopia of great films to choose
from the five-day holiday weekend saw
families split their time between
encanto and ghostbusters afterlife
disney's and kanto a colombian
combination of magic and music topped
the box office with a 40 million dollar
holiday weekend the ghostbusters sequel
was close behind earning 35 million
dollars its second weekend of release at
88 million dollars currently afterlife
is awfully close to becoming the 12th
film of 2021 to cross the 100 million
dollars earned at the domestic box
office the lady gaga led true crime saga
house of gucci opened to 24 million
dollars over the long weekend that haul
makes it the biggest opening for an
adult drama since 2019's little women
the star power wasn't limited to just
gaga as adam driver al pacino selma
hayek and an unrecognizable jared leto
all filled the 158 minute run time and
speaking of 2019 licorice pizza paul
thomas anderson's sprawling 70s la
comedy had the biggest per theater
average of any movie since bong joon
ho's parasite in 2019. licorice pizza
earned 335 thousand dollars from just
four screens the coming of age movie
expands nationwide december 25th but for
now there's just something nice about
pta having the highest pta in two years
tickets for spider-man no way home the
biggest film of the holiday season if
not the year are now on sale to mark the
occasion on cyber um spider monday
fandango's managing editor eric davis
spoke with producer amy pascal about the
future of tom holland spider-man putting
a stop to the this is the end rumors
pascal said this is not the last movie
that we are going to make with marvel
this is not the last spider-man movie
we're getting ready to make the next
spider-man movie with tom holland and
marvel we're thinking of this as three
films and now we're gonna go on to the
next three this is not the last of our
mcu movies pascal also mentioned that we
should expect our first peek at the
spider-man into the spider-verse sequel
very soon and that there are ongoing
discussions on how to bring miles
morales into the live-action world of
the mcu check out more of our interview
with pascal in the link below sticking
with the mcu there's more movement on
mahershala ali's blade the vampire
hunter was unexpectedly introduced in a
post-credits scene in eternals though
he's not seen ali's voice makes it
blade's first appearance in the mcu in
the first casting announcement since the
standalone film was announced in 2019
delroy lindo is in final negotiations to
appear opposite ali and blade lindo's
role is currently unknown filming will
begin in summer of 2022 so we can expect
more casting announcements as well as a
confirmed release date soon and 15 years
after little children were finally
getting a new film from todd fields
field is currently directing cate
blanchett in tar mark strong nina haas
and noemi merlant have also joined the
cast in field's new movie blanchette
plays lydia tarr the first ever female
chief conductor of a major german
orchestra focus features will release
the film on october 7th
2022 there is no doubt that 2021 has
been a great year for movies but the
epic releases are not over yet there are
still a ton of potential box office
blockbusters and oscar-worthy contenders
scheduled to arrive in theaters before
the year comes to a close so from the
matrix to nightmare alley and spiderman
no way home we're here to break it all
down for you here to help us out today
is none other than managing editor at
fandango eric davis eric thanks for
coming on the show
yeah thanks so much for having me it's
good to be back so i gotta know what is
going to be the big movie that everyone
is talking about this holiday season
well it's going to be spiderman no way
home i mean really this is like the
biggest movie that everybody's been
talking about all year long we surveyed
thousands of movie fans heading into
december and spider-man no way home is
the most anticipated film according to
moviegoers and according to me what does
it lead to what else does it open up in
terms of the future of the spider-man
universe a lot of questions still need
to be answered yeah and the trailer is
trickling out even more questions all
along the way that last one was
incredible exactly yes it was you know
and what people should know about this
film in case there's questions peter
parker's identity was revealed at the
end of the last film and so everyone now
knows who he is it's causing disarray in
his life but when he asks dr strange to
cast a spell so that everyone forgets
he's spider-man it opens up this monster
can of worms that involves a crack in
the multiverse that allows spider-man's
greatest foes to return to exact revenge
upon him and so a lot of people are
excited because they're bringing back
villains from previous spider-man films
that starred toby maguire and andrew
garfield and of course a lot of people
are expecting at some point to see those
two as well return and be with tom
holland spider-man and so i think
there's a lot of anticipation for this
kind of film because it is a monster
crossover movie not just with characters
that are currently existing in other
movies but characters we haven't seen
for like over a decade i think that's
cool i'm really looking forward to just
turning into a child in the movie
theaters okay so every year my family we
always go to see a movie so what do you
think would be a fun movie for the whole
family to watch this year i think
there's a couple you know if you have
really young kids i'm going to say sing
too that is a sequel to sing and what i
love about it especially if the words
kids bop mean something to you in your
house
you are going to want to go see sing too
because it's littered with music that is
familiar to kids that's music that's on
the radio now like these cover versions
of the songs and it's got such a great
cast scarlett johansson reese
witherspoon tori kelly john c riley
matthew mcconaughey and they all play
these really great animal characters and
there's always themes in there about
believing in yourself and believing in
your talents and so i think that is a
really great film for little kids but
there's another film with a lot of music
in it and it has a very famous director
attached steven spielberg has a remake
of west side story that just looks
outstanding and gorgeous so i think if
you have some older kids that are also
really like music maybe they didn't see
the original west side story maybe they
didn't see it on broadway as a musical
but this new version is something that i
think a lot of people will really wrap
their arms around plus rita moreno who
was a star in the original west side
story returns and has a role in this one
and so i think that's going to be a film
that a lot of people are talking about
and may even be an awards contender as
well as we get closer to the holidays do
you think there are any other december
movies that could become oscar winners
yeah i mean we could definitely see a
couple in december you know they've been
rolling out over the last couple of
months but there's one from director
guillermo del toro called nightmare
alley that i want to put on everyone's
radar last film that guillermo del toro
directed won best picture and best
director and so i think that he's
somebody that a lot of people are
exciting right now about bradley cooper
stars rooney mara cate blanchett kind of
a remake of a 1947 film also called
nightmare alley and it's about a corrupt
con man who teams up with a female
psychiatrist to trick people into giving
them money i personally love con man
stories and i think with guillermo del
toro at the helm this one's gonna be
really special and then i would also
recommend a film called licorice pizza
it's from one of my favorite writer
directors paul thomas anderson who gave
us like boogie nights and punch drunk
love and i compare licorice pizza to
those two films because it's light and
breezy and fun like those two movies are
this one stars cooper hoffman which is
philip seymour hoffman's son in his
debut and alana heim who is part of that
female trio heim she's in it as well and
it's a coming-of-age story about a 15
year old entrepreneur who falls head
over heels for a girl in her mid-20s and
he doesn't know what to do about it so
if you like coming of age stories and
you like paul thomas anderson movies and
you like heim because the whole family
of time is in this movie no nice
i think you'll you'll really like
licorice pizza doesn't that that movie
also currently have a perfect score on
runt tomatoes i think i think as of this
conversation yes it has a perfect score
and you know the critics that have seen
it have really loved it so far i really
love it i'm a big fan of coming-of-age
movies and and i think they're really
great and especially ones that are about
guys falling for girls and not knowing
how to handle themselves and so uh it's
a really tale as old as time
all right big question here what are
your box office predictions
wow you know i think that there are a
couple of big heavy hitters in terms of
box office you know we haven't had a
film uh in sort of these post pandemic
era that is open to 100 million dollars
on an opening weekend at least in the
united states and so a lot of people are
looking at spider-man no way home as
being like that first movie that breaks
a hundred million at the box office on
its opening weekend and so that film
could really be the biggest money maker
of 2021 which would be interesting
because i'm not sure if in this current
era of sony marvel movies if they've
been able to say that for one of their
films and so i think this one's gonna be
a really big one and also i have my eyes
on the matrix resurrection is probably
right here in terms of anticipation for
me between spider-man and that matrix
movie so i think if there's another film
that's going to make a lot of noise at
the box office it's going to be that
matrix movie because you have keanu
reeves coming back harry and moss coming
back lana wachowski is directing and it
just looks spectacular the kind of film
you want to watch on the big screen so i
would say in terms of box office it's
going to be a healthy box office this
december because it's packed with movies
but look at spider-man and look at
matrix as really paving the way in terms
of those bigger box office grosses
awesome well eric always great to have
you on the show obviously we can find
you on fandango but where else can we
find you go find me on twitter at eric
davis eric with the k uh that's where
you can kind of hang out with me and
listen to all my my crazy movie takes um
and and come over and and say hey and i
always like that
awesome all right thanks again in
theaters on friday is silent night and
wolf
i just think we should be honest with
the kids we know the russians want us
all dead they're sending poisonous gas
to kill us all in the morning it's not
the russians it's the planet it's very
upset
it will kill anything and anyone that is
still alive silent night follows two
parents played by kira knightley and
matthew good who have invited their
closest friends to join their family for
christmas dinner at their idyllic home
in the english countryside as the group
comes together it feels like old times
but behind all of that laughter and
merriment something is not quite right
the world outside is facing impending
doom and no amount of gifts games or
prosecco can make mankind's imminent
destruction go away surviving the
holidays just got a lot more complicated
and available to watch at home is the
last duel and belfast i am risking my
life for you hmm
you are risking
my life
so you can fight your enemy and save
your pride
and that could render our child an
orphan the last duel is a cinematic and
thought-provoking drama set in the midst
of the 100 year war that explores the
power of men the fragility of justice
and the strength and courage of one
woman willing to stand alone in the
service of truth based on actual events
the film unravels long held assumptions
about france's last sanctioned duel
between john de carrouge and jacques
lagree two friends turned bitter rivals
when car rouge's wife marguerite is
viciously assaulted by lagree a charge
he denies she refuses to stay silent
stepping forward to accuse her attacker
an act of bravery that puts her life in
jeopardy matt damon jody comer adam
driver and ben affleck star in ridley
scott's high stakes drama alright well
that's all for today but before you go
leave us a comment and let us know what
you'll be watching this week i'm kale
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you